this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
and we begin tonight with a developing
story in henderson four people are hurt
tonight after police responding to what
they're calling
a shooting incident now this has all
been unfolding near wigwam and green
valley parkway
madison kitten pro joining us now live
from that neighborhood with more on the
case
madison
yeah it's still very active here as you
can see henderson police are still on
scene and i'm going to step out of the
frame
so you can see that there's still a
section of the neighborhood that has
been blocked off
here is what we know so far a shooting
took place around 7
30 this evening off of hunt field drive
here in henderson
four people were injured henderson
police stating that this may be a result
of a domestic dispute
we don't know if the people injured were
all adults or if children were involved
we're also awaiting details on what type
of injuries occurred
all four people were taken to the
hospital their conditions at this time
are unknown so as like i mentioned this
section of the neighborhood is
completely
blocked off we're off of wigwam right
now here in
valley ranch here in henderson so we'll
bring you the very latest once we learn
more information reporting live in
henderson madison kimbrough
8 news now